[Music]
three two one action you guys will come
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want
off the record I'm still gonna do it I
still want to do it today we have and
it's represent that old-school Street
Fighter 2 that's a time and loser
did you just rub your nipples no the
shit's a little talk but maybe what did
you use and who is your favorite can
anyone see know my show is that racist
so I would always use the girl because
I'm a girl and I want to be represented
I only did this move which is upside
down you see you Ryu cuz that I like
karate you see it cuz he's Japanese
I used bison because I was people's type
dealing yeah he just like he was the
boss - I chose E Honda because it was
the only one I could relate to
Honda sumo I like guile - what's her
name Charlie interesting character I
know Charlie Balrog the other one
forgets him I think everyone sleeps on
he basically was Mike Tyson Mike Tyson
but I like this level did you know that
was his name was m.bison in the Japanese
gas and they switched yeah yeah yeah and
bison might close to Mike Tyson ice is
like this and bison yeah yeah so you act
yet I do act I pretend I pretend to act
Shakespeare a little bit yeah I went to
NYU classically trained my mom would be
proud didn't go to med school like
everyone else so your major was like
film I made my both my parents are
doctors that's why did they do the whole
like oh you know it was I'm 103 of an
older brother he went to school for
business and they always thought I was
gonna be the doctor and growing up I
thought I was gonna be the doctor mmm
around 8th grade I was like this sucks
wait you're already going to like
damn do you want your guess he said
early go no like I knew like by the time
I'm like basically can walk and talk my
parents are like you're gonna be a
doctor
oh so we try to brainwash you yeah I
don't need to explain this to you her
parents are doctors you're already
thinking about career paths where yeah
way early like I'm like I'm into this my
dad's my dad's a hand surgeon so he
would project his surgeries on the wall
on like a kodak projector old-school why
he doesn't meeting dinner just like I'd
be sitting there no like I come home
from school and then be on the wall I'm
like what are you doing this out yeah
it's just like some dudes hand that's
split open it wasn't a gynecologist I
never thought about that I never thought
about that Jose mine is like I want to
see [ __ ] do gynecologist do they take
pictures I don't know I've never been to
the culture and they always ask them to
wear lingerie what'd you say he always
makes me spread it well that's not
that's normal right yes examinee right
all of our girlfriends like examinations
always happen at nice hotels really
really nice ones hotel yeah and they
have to you know they have to dress in
long yeah I was told is very painful
because they have to put the duckbill
platypuses evangeline speculum and it's
it's cold right not really comfortable
but does it feel better why don't they
put in the microwave first yeah I don't
know then it's too sensual dude yeah
maybe you know the first time I saw that
was in porn wait what the medical
operator the thing it just looks like
predators mouth doesn't in it doesn't
make a duck bill
it's been just thinking to look at it it
looks like the thing that girls curl
their [ __ ] bill yeah but oh but it's
the other way
yeah but the opposite one yeah so how
did you know when is you're gonna be an
actor so yeah I was like eighth grade
damn great I was like this way because I
was like I gotta convince my parents
you're already acting you know that yeah
like I did like all the school things
the school plays I was I was really into
like martial arts and Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson in martial arts
and so like pence the t-shirt so like I
didn't talk window for a very long time
and that's it like obsessed with Jackie
Chan Bruce Lee oh that's did you grow up
in a minority neighborhood no not at all
I would say in a small town called
Mahopac New York which is in Putnam
County got in like an hour north take an
hour north you're seeing words right now
it's it's outside of the Bronx all like
everyone knows where that Syracuse
no we're far from them and I only know
New York you know I'm kind of thinking
over Scarsdale is chap Buffalo know very
far from that I know where the school
where the Clintons would live here okay
we don't know anything it's an hour no
more educated than the rest of us okay
it's all good did they have roles that
like fit you because I remember we
watched I watched Wizard of Oz and since
I went to school like 50% Asians like
The Wizard was Asian the lion was Asian
there was just a bunch of Lies all
staged yeah
I played the Scarecrow in high school oh
cool does ever they had to pay my face
oh yeah I I could have any race and this
is the [ __ ] Scarecrow straw I'm
trying to think now I'm trying to think
volatile hidin was Asian as [ __ ] it was
you know kid-friendly musicals yeah
anybody could be I did I did do Jesus
Christ Superstar and I did play Judas oh
no you know the ultimate they would have
the dark guy played Judah Zachary like
everyone was white and had the one brown
can be like that the ultimate biblical
villain I know I always thought in my in
my house I have
the [ __ ] Last Supper and I always
thought how did you call it [ __ ]
laugh whatever the [ __ ] thing it is
the last I'm talking about before
something in rectangle people well yeah
the [ __ ] Last Supper amen
and so I remembered the Judas was to do
with the [ __ ] with the bag the coin
purse I was at that fool was the dopest
and then my dad was like no he betrayed
Jesus I think but he has money yes I
used to like Judas a lot he's conspiring
in that in that piece he's kind of like
having that secret yeah yeah I thought
he was rich no our family would use who
thus he was Lord Baelish he was Lord
Baelish who dies call you like a
backstabber they're like [ __ ] who did
you guys do that also have to do that
also [ __ ] Chinese [ __ ] so you
have the [ __ ] you know the the
inkblot where you would see Jesus Christ
no well we saw it in bread tortilla if
you would have maria this is very famous
inkblot where you see the face of jesus
christ and there was just thing that
they would always say and creatures if
you can't see jesus then you're a sinner
and you're going to help I couldn't see
if I was like sixteen so I just thought
I wasn't you know [ __ ] oh that's like a
magic eye Hey but it like you just came
to you when you're sixteen I just I just
cross my eyes a little bit and then it
came out you think you've got the pouty
like found your power well I just
thought that was a good Christian now
that well I could see I could see
Jesus's face but my parents would just
it was a joke I didn't know you know so
I just thought I was a tournament video
squared that final when he got boners
you can see Jesus face yeah like did
that all throughout high school and
convinced my parents it wasn't you know
if I think if I was really terrible at
you know I want to be an actor and we
did a lot of musicals so I used to
seeing and that kind of stuff if I
really if I really sucked I think my
parents would be the first person to be
like you know what because you suck just
forget it
yeah maybe because it wasn't an
overnight thing
cuz you seem dedicated yeah it was it
was no years in the making
he wants to dance yeah so they're
they're very very supportive you know I
talk to other Asian kids and Indians and
you know they they don't they different
yeah but see I feel like your step is so
different though because a lot of Asian
kids that I talk to they don't do the
work to show that they can do it
well you know I just kind of approach it
like anything else I was like you know
if you want to be a basketball player or
tennis player the parents are gonna
throw it with piano right do the scales
a million times so if I showed them oh I
can do this and I want to do it by
myself and I show them the initiative
yup then they'll just get off my back
that's and that's what I always say -
like I always wish there would be more
kids that have that story a
responsibility yeah because there's
always a story I was like my parents
don't believe in me as I but you don't
put in the work so how would ya exactly
I would I don't believe in you exactly
but it's just I think from a parent's
point of view just scary because you
know they immigrated to this country
they want to give you a better life and
you want a [ __ ] bats in a play yeah
coins oh you know they're probably
sitting in the plays he wants to be a
straw man what the [ __ ] yeah he's trying
so hard - I know why are you trying so
hard he's probably born that way aren't
you it's like oh we didn't have shoes
and in applauds like all the stuff I
told you my dad my dad's want to eat so
in he's the youngest so I can't I kind
of believe that you know if you well he
told me he's like I didn't have shoes
until I was eight and I was like what
are you talking about you probably got
good feet probably I got my dancing
moves from I show up I'm like I want to
be an actor and poor for the rest of my
life you know that's the kind of really
upsetting but it all it all worked out
what's four years of like theater or
like film eight like what what does that
feel you're acting major [ __ ] no
it's it's uh I would say it's half and
half it's different it's really kind of
what you make of it especially school
NYU who are known for film you have so
many outlets and so many opportunities
to kind of expose yourself and learn and
train and I wonder students classes that
you take so like freshman year I took I
had one I can run my schedule I had
movement in the morning which is
basically walking or no it's like just
getting to know your body it's this yeah
like don't be like stand up I remember
our first class with the master teacher
was we just had to stand up straight for
an hour [ __ ] that I'm dropping out
immediately would fate I don't be like
lot knees and everything yeah you just
stand just stand up just relax just
stand like laziest I'm there like you're
gonna stand there and I'm like this is
gonna be [ __ ] easy and of course like
15 minutes in someone hits the floor and
I'm like what stuff I would not be able
to stand still for an hour I would lose
my father just you'll be surprised you
know people are all like physically
awkward if you go hey walk across the
stage and you're like why do you walk
with the stick up your ass
and then you realize oh that's just how
that person cuz they're only thinking
upper body it's not even that it you
don't even know what's going through
their head they're not connected yeah
exactly they're just not thinking oh I'm
a different person you know my person
may walk differently have different gait
just have different energy and you're
like why are you walking that way and
it's the purpose of the class is so that
you can get attuned with your own body
that you're able to make choices then
are that are different from you a lot
can't happen from staying still so I do
this thing with my the the karate place
that I train at we do 90-minute horse
dances yes impossible and so here this
thing starts happening when you're
forced to stay correct in one position
and you're doing it with a group yeah
cuz it's you're not no one's ever gonna
be able to do this alone you'll break
like a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah when
you see this like understanding and you
start getting bored too so you start
exploring and isolating different parts
of your body and not only that just
dealing with that stillness is the most
terrifying thing any human being has to
go through that should smoking hard
especially for me cuz I'm fidgety as
hell they didn't do the tea cup tea cup
challenge for you guys what's the hair
make you stand in a horse tain't horse
stance and they will put boiling teacups
on your thighs oh that's that bad no we
just have shown that if you break it the
water if the whole point is that you
have to keep the horse dance long enough
so that the water cools down yeah Korean
ass [ __ ] instructor huh oh yeah no we
would just do 90-minute horse - there
were two white guys do
one-nothing they made that [ __ ] up
that's what they told me so there I'm
trying to think the grand master was
Korean and then we had a master I don't
know what is where he was from
he was brown you'd think he was Filipino
Oh crab master Sanchez Chung ma that was
his name
Chung mom yeah it's pretty crazy just
the simplest things that I realized like
I didn't connect with my lower body or
like I didn't even think and feel my
feet
yeah just different parts like yeah just
about awareness so then like you know
they do that then you have your normal
like here's their scene study class
here's our script analysis class and
then we have voice and speech which just
focuses on talking like training your
voice to project project be audible be
clear strengthening kind of like don't
sound like you can give the news right
now yeah I could try it take over yeah
no I can use that enunciate back to
school they do the weird voice though
cuz I I know a couple minutes
yeah like newscasters don't talk the way
they talk on TV yeah hello like today
we're on [ __ ] George Takei he talks
like that all the time yeah does all the
time hello David it's really great to
meet you I was like hey bro have you
heard him take a [ __ ] it's the same way
yeah cuz I did like this I forgot what
it was but it was something through
YouTube right I got to work with him and
then it threw me off why is he still
talking he's always in character yeah he
goes you're very funny humble brag that
you just did though George Takei well no
you're really funny I like that how most
people to know but George Takei though I
freaked out when I met him because he's
somebody that I saw growing up as a kid
yeah of course but nobody else gave a
[ __ ] but for me I just saw him growing
up yes I'm [ __ ] George Takei so you
know nobody always at the Asian Film
Festival dude that's a shame he's a
forefront of a lot of things dude Asian
people and gay people he's you know
funny leave me up Scottie
no that's a different he's so [ __ ]
tired of that [ __ ]
his our manager is also his husband oh
yeah very nice good I bet you they final
takes a cut all things it takes up the
ass you still think he takes his money
I'm pretty sure yeah what do they do
they just share it I guess a separate
banking on how good he's in bed you're
bad I'm gonna take 50% today I would do
that I'll use that as leverage that's so
cool so fast-forward to now they won't
be other projects have you worked um so
my most recent project was a show called
Russian doll that was on Netflix store
sounds sexy it's great show that the one
where it keeps repeating yeah no you
guys have seen it I wanted to watch it I
gotta check it out you guys should watch
it's really good I play I don't give
away too much for anyone that home
browsers okay I'll watch it now it's
great it's highly reviewed look it up
you know I think it's got like a 99% of
rotten tomatoes oh it did have a hundred
at one cuz I watched a preview and I was
like this is dope and then there was a
flat earth documentary and watch that
instead you clicked on that one too yeah
is it a guy that he has like yet he's
wearing a t-shirt that says like flat
earthers yeah what's their argument so
well basically the whole documentary is
exploring the whole culture the world
and everything okay and it's based off
of this guy I think he's called like the
general or the captain or he's like
those dad Captain America yeah he's like
a really popular guy I forgot his name
but uh okay Grand Master flat earth yeah
but it's it's it's really like about the
whole community and and you know how
everyone kind of believes the same thing
and it's just a whole entire world it's
interesting everyone that's like a loser
though we should have them do horse
dances we should have them do the keep
the tea cup test and see it's pretty
funny you should watch it all right what
else what else so I did Russian doll
before that I was on a show called
stitchers which was on freeform we did
three seasons of that's canceled what's
freeform it used to be ABC family family
yeah so yeah most people don't know that
is it no it was on TV ah I know nobody
even knows
I feel like I don't know I mean just TV
shows coming in all the time yeah yeah
no but they they kind of I don't know
why they ABC family became freeform and
then nobody knew what the network was
called still today changed me cuz
they're not a family network anymore cuz
yeah I used to laugh cuz I think like on
Pretty Little Liars the teachers used to
hook up with the students like in the
story of the show knows like that's
really family-oriented I was like isn't
this aren't they 16 really change the
brand new because I guess this rape on
the show so what's going on but like
knowing character yeah yeah werewolf
[ __ ] Marvel [ __ ] like death and stuff so
it's not really family yeah they're
moving away towards you know and moving
towards kind of more adult content so
they were like we got a drop family
let's go with freeform which I thought
was this just a weird name cuz it was
called it like a ABC ABC - yeah then MTV
one MTV just like one two three there
you go I want to remember that I went to
DC and one two three like all the
Disney's should just be a b c d e f g h
i j yeah yeah that's ESPN changes c we
should be coming up with me XYZ yeah
they have enough channels yeah they do
now they own it well we took JK so they
can't use that yeah we only got two
letters after Ella gkf mm-hm
yeah so I'm like now so I had stitchers
and then I had the jungle book before
that so the movie the movie yeah Oh play
Mowgli's father and I did all the motion
capture for Mowgli which was cool cuz I
got to work with Jon Favreau every day
for basically nine months is it cool guy
great guy love him you have to say that
no I don't say this and if he ever sees
this I yeah I hope he laughs about it
there were certain times where I was
like I basically did the whole movie for
all the graphic artists and the motion
capture artists and that kind of stuff
and there was one point where I was
doing a scene and it was it was an
emotional scene and I look over and I
just see him and he's playing clash of
clans on his phone
I'm like if you wanted to impress me god
damn it I was like ah man well I'll be
back tomorrow another day do you call
them John yeah I call John calm John
John yeah but he's a great guy
super smart that's so funny can't wait
for Lion King
that just goes to show no matter how
important your work is Oh everyone gets
bored if everyone gets bored and I get
it you know there's nothing in the room
it's like me and emotion caps or shoot
with a bunch of all the likes the little
else yeah it's not like the set and
there's a river and foliage you're
expecting him to be like captivated by a
performance and he's just like I've
never seen anything like yeah he's like
you know what I'm gonna hire you for the
next movie right you're my I look over
and he's just like [ __ ] like my comic
clan my clan is getting wrong watching
amateur porn and [ __ ] gonna dick to the
faces like yeah how does even know if
you like that take or not because he can
go back and watch it it was really crazy
it was just like I'm just gonna go three
takes of this no madam Karen yeah I mean
it was more they were doing so much new
stuff with kind of the computer
technology yeah before that movie that I
think half of it was just like yeah well
look at it and post or whatever the
computers and they can because he could
go in afterwards and basically change
the angle and the view and zoom in and
zoom out and there was some really
pretty amazing stuff so it was cool yeah
that's where I'm at trapped I swamp
yeah he's insane yeah so him and I got
close on that so I know like Travis and
been appalling all the jam guys yeah so
yeah so Travis was was basically my
stunt guy okay so any time I was like
alright we're gonna roll down a hill and
I was like sure Travis break away he
also did stunts for Mobley - I don't
know
yeah so it was what what happened was
they didn't have a kid yeah they didn't
have Neil cast yet so and they had to
get started with the movie and the
artists had to start building the world
and all the animals so we basically did
the easiest way describe is like I would
put on the suit and then I'd put on an
oculus rift and then I would have a
one-to-one like I would see myself in 3d
form but as a child
Oh
yes oh no B me like running around like
Mowgli in the loincloth the hair and the
puppeteer has also had like puppet like
motion capture puppets that were the
animals so for like the Panther there
was two actors like for the front legs
and the back legs in the front the
person who had the front legs would talk
and we would film it that way and then
basically what you get is like a really
rough looking like PlayStation 1 version
of the movie ah and they kind of just
use it for storyboarding or you know pre
visuals previous that's what they call
it so then once they hired the kid they
were like this is kind of what we want
to do and then he'd go in and he copied
all your work maybe I don't want to say
that yeah he was inspired he was fired
okay we'll call it coffee
yeah and copy that [ __ ]
[Music]